katusha
pas
tous
[Musique]
une grande acadienne qui était être lésé
panthéon des auteurs et compositeurs
canadiens
oui on va la voir dans la tête toute la
journée cette chanson de paquetville ça
s'est passé hier cette intronisation à
moncton le cadre du congrès mondial
acadien pour parce qu'elle est une
pionnière une ambassadrice incontesté de
la culture acadienne et donc elle
rejoint adhérents assez important félix
leclerc fait partie du panthéon beau
dommage aussi la nôtre comme johnny
miccio tout un chemin parcouru pour être
battus depuis le début de sa carrière au
milieu des années 60 et son premier
album de 1973 quand j'ai commencé je
pensais jamais que d'abord que ce centre
est sinon temps de 55 ans que je gagne
ma vie avec ça et c'est mon année
chanceuse par cette année je 60 et 17 en
deux sets
51 42 carrés à 5 5 alors seulement
d'année chanceuse et jeu tellement
content parce que je suis que c'est pas
juste moi non plus qui veut rentrer au
panthéon c'est toute la culture d'un
peuple qui rend quand même temps c'est
tout ce qu'il ya avec mon nouveau
toujours les affiliés la cad dire qu'à
bienne paquet de lille est fait battre
le enregistré 250 chansons au cours de
sa carrière mais c'est certain qu'on se
souvient d'abord et avant tout de
paquetville son plus grand succès aligné
à paquetville au nouveau brunswick est
ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle en a assez de
l'interpréter est-ce que parfois elle
voudrait l'exclure de ses spectacles
mais encore maintenant les airs fouet au
nom les gens sont tellement contents
d'eux cachant pas sa frappe sa frappe
jusqu à varages de la charte à toutes
les fois pour moi c'est comme si calais
nouvelle parce que je vois les gens qui
sourient
les voit danser j'ai même vu du monde à
l'entrée avec des béquilles sorti aux
éditions paquet ville sait pas que c'est
une chance miraculeuse miraculeuse le
dernier album dédié de butler remonte à
2013 et disait jésus et en sortir un
autre l'industrie du disque se vend mal
ça nous prend beaucoup d'argent est bien
là elle nous apprend qu'elle va entrer
en studio plus tard cette année en
novembre et vont enregistrer de
nouvelles chansons donc des chansons
qu'on pourrait très certainement
attendre l'année prochaine prévient
merci stéphane plaisir